the opening scene begins with a
metaphorical depiction of men as wild
horses instinctively yearning for
freedom and autonomy to roam and Grace
without constraints Jimmy the main
character resonates with this notion
suggesting that he shares this desire
for unrestrained Independence the scene
shifts to a restaurant where Jimmy is
seen in the midst of breaking up with
his 13th girlfriend implying that he has
had many relationships in the past at
the same time behind Jimmy a girl named
Anne is also ending her relationship
with her partner in the atmosphere is
tense and uncomfortable as both couples
Partners storm off in Anger Jimmy and
Dan find themselves alone just then and
expresses her desire to have lunch with
Jimmy which he agrees to instantly it
takes no time for them to get into a new
relationship if only we all had it as
easy as Jim in the next scene we are
shown a wedding where one of Jimmy's
friends is getting married a
long-standing tradition stipulates that
whoever's girlfriend catches the bride's
bouquet will be the next couple to marry
despite their wild and free-spirited
nature Jimmy and his friends are
eventually Tethered to the institution
of marriage by this societal expectation
and one by one they succumbed to the
pressure and tie the knot in one of his
friends weddings the same tradition
unfolds as the bride tosses her bouquet
to the awaiting crowd to Jimmy's dismay
the bouquet is caught by none other than
Anne causing him to feel a sense of
unease and concern for the future of his
freedom as he returns home he sifts
through old photos of his ex-girlfriends
all of whom have represented a certain
degree of Liberty and Independence in
his life in the background the sounds of
thousands of horses running echoes
perhaps serving as a reminder of his
previous wild and free-spirited
existence or maybe all them horses are
trying to tell Jim that he's gay later
Jimmy sits with his grandfather a man
who has experienced the very sin
conflict between individuality and
marriage life the grandfather urges
Jimmy to embrace the societal
expectations of marriage and procreation
sharing his own sacrifice of wild and
carefree living in favor of family and
Legacy he even offers Jimmy an
engagement ring signaling his desire to
see his grandson conform to the Norms of
society despite his reluctance Jimmy
ultimately decides to propose to Anne
after three years of dating that evening
he takes her to an extravagant
restaurant to express his proposal
however it proves to be a difficult task
because of his nervousness Jimmy
indirectly mentions that he had a desire
to remain Wild and Free like a horse but
eventually Anne won him over this
statement leaves Zan feeling confused so
she asks him what she has won to which
Jimmy responds that one cannot stay
loyal to one toilet Forever Without
defecating nice unfortunately Anne
becomes angry with him for saying
something so distasteful and such a
romantic setting she also comes to
realize that Jimmy doesn't really want
to get married he simply wants to live
his Bachelor Life feeling enraged and
decides to go home and confide
everything to her sister Natalie she
explains how everything went well except
for Jimmy's proposal upon hearing this
Natalie assumes that Jimmy may have
written a beautiful speech but lost it
causing him to improvise and say
something inappropriate however Anne
isn't willing to accept any excuses with
all that talk about horses she knows
Jimmy's dumb as a brick she believes
that this is a once in a lifetime moment
for both of them and she really wanted
him to do it right which he didn't after
the disastrous proposal Jimmy tries to
make amends by sending in flowers every
day but despite his attempts to contact
her she refuses to answer his calls
meanwhile the news of Jimmy's
embarrassing proposal spreads like
wildfire throughout the city leaving him
feeling ashamed a few days later Jimmy
receives the sad news of his
grandfather's passing and at the funeral
and finally pays him a visit during
their conversation Jimmy asks her about
their relationship to which she responds
that the door has not been closed yet
and if there is a nice knock she may
answer it giving him a glimmer of hope
just don't tell me I'm a toilet you want
to poop in again all right however
things take an unexpected turn when
Jimmy discovers that his grandfather has
left him the family business and a
substantial amount of wealth but under
certain conditions the first condition
is that he must be married by 605 pm on
his 30th birthday which happens to be
just one day away the second condition
is that he and his wife cannot be apart
for more than a week at a time over the
next 10 years and they must try to have
a child within the first five years of
their marriage in case Jimmy doesn't
succeed his business rival Odin Sports
will acquire the complete company as a
result the unmarried man along with his
companions and the clergyman must hurry
to find a suitable bride within the next
few hours in the next scene Jimmy
immediately heads to find Anne only to
discover that she has left for further
studies in Athens however this time he
is not going to give up so easily
determined to propose to her before it's
too late he rushes to the heliport and
thankfully makes it just in time clad in
a dashing tuxedo Jimmy gets down on one
knee and pours his heart out to Anne
urging her to say yes however Anna's
taken aback by his sudden appearance and
the presence of a priest behind in the
car she questions whether Jimmy is truly
ready to give up his bachelor lifestyle
causing him to hesitate and reminisce
about his wild days all those horses
this moment of Doubt causes Annie to
realize that Jimmy is not yet ready to
fully commit and she hastily departs in
the helicopter leaving Jimmy feeling
lost however despite her initial
decision to continue on to Athens Anne
has a change of heart and returns to her
apartment where she confides in her
sister Natalie suggests that they visit
their parents for the night giving in
time to think about her feelings and in
the situation with Jimmy meanwhile Jimmy
is faced with a tough decision himself
he could remain single and forfeit the
wealth that he inherited from his
grandfather or he could marry one of his
Old Flames and retrieve the fortune
saving the jobs of hundreds of workers
employed by the company with no other
options left Jimmy reluctantly turns to
a shoebox full of old photos of his
ex-girlfriends after which he embarks on
a quest to track them down and convince
them to marry him Jimmy's journey to
find a suitable bride takes him on a
roller coaster ride of emotions as he
encounters various ex-girlfriends in
search of his future wife he first goes
to a girl named Stacy with whom he
enjoyed several romantic dates in the
past unfortunately she is already
engaged to someone and when Jimmy learns
about this he is dejected next up is Zoe
a window dresser who appears to be very
cheerful as soon as Jimmy approaches her
she eagerly jumps into his arms thrilled
that he thought of her after being
rejected by Anne their chemistry is
palpable and it seems like Jimmy's
proposal May finally succeed but just as
things are heating up he hears Anne's
voice and abruptly runs off after a
woman he believes to be her however his
mistake becomes apparent and by the time
he returns to Zoe she has set a
mannequin on fire in a fit of rage
Jimmy's next attempt at finding a bride
leads him to his actress ex-girlfriend
Ilana who flat out refuses his proposal
stating that she is not one to chase
after money why do you think I got into
the art stupid feeling discouraged but
not defeated Jimmy sets his sights on
Carolyn a graduate student who is
fiercely independent and a feminist at
heart despite her initial interest in
Jimmy she refuses to be used as a mere
commodity to retrieve his grandfather's
wealth leaving him to ponder his next
move the day goes from bad to worse for
Jimmy when his car breaks down so he
along with his friend Marco and the
weary priest continue their search by a
local bus on the flip side Annie and her
sister arrive at their parents house and
are greeted warmly however the visit
does not seem to change their mood
because their parents excessive display
ways of affection irritates them while
eating dinner the mother excuses herself
to go to the restroom but the father
calls out to her saying he already
misses her oh lovey-dovey
liar unable to Bear any more of their
lovey-dovey moments Ann and Natalie's
storm out of the house meanwhile Jimmy
proceeds to the police station to meet
his next girlfriend Daphne who happens
to be a police officer even though
Daphne has to deal with criminals on a
daily basis she still manages to
preserve her beauty however when she
realizes that Jimmy is proposing to her
solely for his inheritance she confronts
him and delivers a resounding Will Smith
oh wow eventually Jimmy's list of
ex-girlfriends runs out but he does
manage to convince his final Choice an
arrogant girl named Buckley who despises
him a lot without delay she is fitted
with a bridal dress and prepared for the
wedding however as the priest attempts
to conduct the ceremony Buckley
gradually becomes aware of the other
stipulations of the will At first she
learns about the requirement to be
together for 10 years which she believes
is doable as she can get half of Jimmy's
wealth however when Buckley discovers
that she must have a baby within five
years she is unable to Bear the pressure
and drives away as everyone scrambles to
convince the girl to come back Jimmy
realizes that he has only 17 hours left
before the contract expires in the
morning Jimmy and the priests are in a
park surrounded by happy couples the
sight of the couple's prompts the priest
to share his own experience of having a
successful marriage he reveals that he
was married for 26 years and had a large
family with four sons and 10
grandchildren my family likes sex a
whole lot says the priest he speaks
fondly of his wife and how much he loved
her even after her death he still
believes that getting married was the
best decision he ever made according to
the priest true happiness comes from
being with someone who loves you and
will grow old with you Jimmy is moved by
the priest's story and he begins to see
the importance of marriage he realizes
that he has been thinking about Anne
constantly and cannot stop himself from
wanting to be with her afterwards Jimmy
who has not slept all night is asked to
rest for a while in a church where Marco
had promised to deliver a bride by that
evening elsewhere and Mrs Jimmy and
decides to return to the city she tries
to reach him on the phone but in vain
she then calls Marco and asks him to
arrange a dinner with Jimmy however it's
too late because Marco has already
published an ad in the newspaper
announcing that whoever marries Jimmy
before 6 PM can win 100 million dollars
this announcement causes a frenzy among
women who want to marry Jimmy for the
money numerous women around the city
start to dress up as brides and rush to
the church to try and win the prize
money in the next scene Jimmy wakes up
to a surreal site of hundreds of women
surrounding him all of whom are
interested in the eligible bachelor as
he tries to make sense of the situation
he realizes that the women are becoming
increasingly aggressive in their pursuit
of him just as he is unable to handle
the situation his friend Marco appears
and claims that it was all just a prank
he tries to convince the women to leave
but they are still not willing to let
Jimmy go so easily in the midst of all
this chaos Jimmy and DeMarco find a room
to hide in while they are hiding Marco
reveals that Anne is on her way back
which makes Jimmy ecstatic he
immediately rushes to the train station
to meet her ordering a cake on the way
despite being pursued by the brides he
somehow manages to make it to the
station when Jimmy finds Anne she has
already seen the news headline with his
picture and the question would you marry
this man for 100 million dollars and is
understandably upset but Jimmy finally
confesses his true feelings for her he
tells her that she is the most precious
gift and the most romantic story of his
life he truly wishes to be with her for
the rest of their lives moved by his
words and finally agrees to marry him as
she heads to the restroom to change into
a wedding dress the rally of brides
arrives there after a wild Chase through
the city Jimmy makes his way up a flight
of stairs on a fire escape he then calls
out for Anne as the pack of brides
closes in on him luckily she is able to
weave her way through the throng of
women and reached Jimmy's side from
inside a police car the priest
officiates the wedding over a
loudspeaker which causes many of the
brides to attack the car but despite the
chaos and delivers a heartfelt message
to the crowd about her relationship with
Jimmy which finally calms The Other
Women down following this the priest
completes the ceremony by declaring
Jimmy and Anna's husband and wife the
crowd now delighted to witness the
couple's Union cheers loudly for them
Jimmy and Dan make it just in time
before the deadline of 605 pm to inherit
the 100 million dollars kinda shocked
they didn't miss the deadline it would
have made for a more meaningful ending I
think the movie ends as Anne tosses her
bouquet into the teeming crowd below
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching